- You're a dad now and your
daughter just turned two.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Yeah.
- This is so cool.
- That's my chookie.
That's my chookie-chookie.
- I love the 70s party.
- Oh yeah.
- So like-
- You know, first year was in Kanto.
- Oh, my God. What a first!
What a great first birthday.
- Her first year was in Kanto
and we made her her own magical door too.
It was pretty cool.
- Oh, my gosh.
I wish I'd given you that picture.
Anyways, I snoozed out.
- I like what I'm creating
in my head anyway.
It's so magical.
(Wilmer Valderrama laughs)
Whole art team in my head.
That's amazing though, the 70s thing.
Did you bring out Fez?
For this party?
- Well, what you saw
me wearing there was one
of Fez's classic outfits.
(audience laughs)
It was-
- You still fit in it?
Screw you (laughs)!
- Girl,
it's called my one hour a day.
(Kelly and audience laugh and applaud)
- I can promise you my one hour a day
will not be working out (laughs).
(audience applauds and cheers)
My one hour a day will look like this.
(Wilmer laughs)
(laughs) I just wanna sit.
I love that.
The in Kanto birthday. That's so cool.
Wait, what's just happening (laughs)?
- [Wilmer] It's a long story
but if you guys go to my Instagram
I think you'll get more context.
(audience laughs)
- I am just very happy for you
that you fit in it.
That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- Go you. Go you.
- (audience applauds)